to this computer
welcome everybody to this very special
edition
of the into the impossible podcast with
your fearful host
professor brian keating chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at
the university of california san diego
and co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
and arthur c clarke was of course very
fascinated with things
fanciful science fiction related and
even
constructing things science fiction
related on the surface of the moon
and today we're talking with a frequent
guest a friend of the show
a friend of the center and a big thinker
dr james beacham
uh who i have yet to meet in person but
he's been a
multi-time guest on the show he's really
a big thinker he's an innovator
and he's an experimentalist like me but
that means
as i've told my ideological children if
not my biological children
who i do tell on occasion uh to be an
experimentalist is an important uh
is different than being a theorist our
theorists who james and i
know and love uh we our colleagues we
we have to know the theory as well as
the experiment which is a one-way
kind of direction not to say that you
know the best the best theorists do know
the theory
and experiment very well but they don't
actually do the experiment
uh the best experimentalists have to
know the theory
maybe not create new theories but they
have to do the experiment and know the
theory
so it's a different branch of physics
and i like to bring to you my audience
my beloved audience
from time to time a technical level of
talk that shows you cutting edge
physics and even beyond what we're
capable of doing now
because as a kennedy brother once said
uh man's
or woman's uh reach should always exceed
his or her grasp
and i think you know some of these
innovative things well they might be
poo-pooed now
by certain uh theoretically inclined
people so too would would things
even by the creators of the theory a
hundred years ago like einstein
famously saying that things like
gravitational lensing gravitational
waves would never be of a
detectability and should not be even
taken seriously
and he would only do them as a favor to
certain friends of his
it's funny because they he would do
these calculations and then they'd be
published in nature
which i don't think you know james and i
can do that in our papers
but anyway james is joining us uh he's a
eminent physicist
he's also doing yeoman's work because i
think james and i agree
that a scientist nowadays uh he or she
must also engage with the public
james and i are supported um you know in
my case supported uh
from my very earliest ages as a as a
public school kid
um i went to uh public high school
public um you know elementary school all
the way to
high school went to case western then i
went to
to brown and then finally i ended up
here as a professor at a state school
in california uh james i'm sure any one
of us james who has been sponsored
by a university research grant or a
public
uh national uh you know grant from the
national science foundation department
of energy grant
we rely on the beneficence of the public
and i feel like we have to give back and
james you do a phenomenal job giving
back both
on um and your public talks in your
in your research online that you present
and and you've been also on some
on some movies as well and i just want
to salute you for doing that i i believe
myself
i joke it's kind of a uh it's kind of my
moral obligation to do it
and uh maybe maybe that's taking it a
little too seriously
but i do want to salute you you do so
much great outreach i love your twitter
feed
um and i love uh i love of course more
than anything the research that you do
but you're an experimentalist today
we're going to take a little uh tour
both your personal world line what got
you so excited about physics
and just imagine somewhere out there
there's a young james or a young
um jamona jenny whatever somebody out
there
who could be inspired yeah to take a
voyage
into the impossible to learn about what
it takes to build stuff with his or her
hands
to explore the micro world and connect
it to the macro world
of the greater universe so james with
that i'll ask you to take it away
and talk about a big bang machine on the
surface of earth's closest neighbor
the moon james take it away well
thanks extremely to you uh brian because
uh thanks for the kind words and thanks
thanks for the uh the platform the
opportunity um and i say platform
because i really really enjoy uh your
audience every time i've been on here
and we got
wonderful questions after after the
facts and great interactions it's
just really phenomenal what you put
together here so back at you with the
bravo and the the kudos and the
saludos it's uh fantastic stuff um and i
love the fact that you know every time i
you know every few months or something i
check your uh subscribers on youtube and
it just keeps going up man so keep it
going
keep it going i like it um and i like it
even more so because like so many
podcasts and things are very much
on the sort of um you know especially
science minded ones they're very kind of
like
they can get super into kind of
speculative territory but they
they so often you know because that gets
a lot of clicks and things like that
but not as often as what you do is you
sort of like bring it down and kind of
ground it and i really like that
and to me that sort of is a nice match
with some of the stuff that i end up
thinking about just sort of naturally
um because so the the reason that i'm
ostensibly here is just a few days ago
one of my collaborators and i put a
paper on the archive um
that made uh the entirety of the high
energy physics uh community sort of
start scratching their heads
um some of them i think were inspired
some were uh confused and then
a few other ones were really kind of um
kind of intrigued and i've had a huge
panoply of responses so far to this and
it really was
um a it's not a proposal it's it's not a
concrete proposal in any way but it
really is from an experimental
experimentalist perspective
an examination of what it would take for
us to build a large hadron collider
style collider
that instead of 27 kilometers around
circles around the entire circumference
of a great circle of the moon
which is 11 000 kilometers and so i i
like the opportunity to be here so that
you know i can kind of motivate that in
a certain way right because what if you
hear that and you're
you know if you're a science minded
person you kind of understand maybe
but not really understand completely why
bigger is better if you're completely in
the public you hear this you're like
wait what what do how do these things go
together what is the
exposure blah blah blah so i really
really enjoy this opportunity to kind of
you know
take it a little bit deep and you know
there's a clarification here
i have been talking about such a project
for many years now
um and i gave some public talks about it
2018 there's a talk that i gave that you
can find the video for on
at the royal institution um and at the
time it was very much a you know kind of
just an inspirational tool right it's an
idea for people to get inspired by it's
like wow and cheap whiz and it's big and
you know i was like yeah we in principle
maybe this could happen but the whole
crux of that talk at the time in 2018
was that
i didn't know what the details were
because i'd never done the numbers that
never bothered to go through it
um i knew what the motivation for it was
what the big idea was
but in terms of the real numbers no one
had ever done it
so just you know i finally got around to
doing it and uh um
that's what i'm going to be talking
about here um because it's kind of wild
what we can get into
so the first thing that i want to you
know
emphasize with people is that you know
right now as far as i'm concerned this
is like
the most the most interesting time and
the most amazing time to be a scientist
you know ever like to be alive in the
history of of science because
you can think back you know hundreds of
years ago when people were
you know before before like uh you know
ptolemy and copernicus and galileo and
like
you know things were very kind of
interesting and moving around and those
were big steps forward that were made
and the
scientific questions that were being
debated were very huge but right now
we're at this
really important part in human history
where we have so many huge open
questions
in basic physics and we're kind of out
of we have run out of big hints as to
what we should do
to answer these questions and i think as
your audience would know right things
like dark matter we know the dark matter
exists
we've known that exists empirically it's
just it's proven that something called
dark matter exists we have no clue what
it is
still we've been looking for this for
decades we know that the universe is
expanding you know and a few billion
years ago
it ended up just starting to accelerate
as expansion for some reason
we don't know why we have good ideas but
we do not have uh we don't have that
answer to that we don't know why our
universe is made of matter
and not anti-matter we don't know the
answer to this and the problem with the
the crux of this moment is that we have
these big open questions
but like i said we're sort of out of the
big hints and that's where this thing
you mentioned with respect to that the
kind of dichotomy
between theorists and experimentalists
comes in theorists that's
no that's their day job right it's like
they're supposed to come up with these
ideas and new ideas as to how to test
things and
in principle you know kind of dig into
those the details of the math and
the implications blah blah blah and in
the past the 20th century was
filled with so many hints that ended up
just being kind of like bing you should
go over here and you'll find this and
there it was
you should go over here and find this
and there it was and we're sort of out
of those
so i want to just kind of i'm going to
get into this in a little bit of detail
here but i really just want to emphasize
that to my mind
it this is the most important this is
the most amazing time to be alive
as a scientist because we get to look at
things like this so to my mind
there we go please there we go so this
is an event display and some of your
audience might know a little bit about
the large hadron collider but this is a
this is a
uh an event display that we that we this
is something we refer to as an event
display in the atlas experiment which is
the one that i work on
and it's one of the big experiments of a
large hadron collider and what this
shows is you had more or less this kind
of cylindrical geometry
you had two protons at extremely high
energies that came in both sides of this
thing
they slammed together in the middle and
they managed to shoot out two hydronic
jets
in opposite directions and if you recap
if you reconstruct the invariant mass of
these two
jets objects you get some 9.5 tev
before 2015 our species could never have
even
considered looking at something like
this this is
like the you know this this is this is
the highest energy stuff we've ever seen
in our lives
and the reason and of course the machine
that made this
uh this uh you know um the machine that
made this of course
is the oh and just for so some people
might know um
they might understand a little bit here
but just a quick note on the notation so
in collider physics we often use uh this
so-called natural units and so this is
where h-bar equals c
equals one and we usually measure mass
and energy in the same units which is eb
or some fraction of those or some you
know uh order magnitude of that so this
is tev
an electron for example has a mass of
about half an med an electron zipping
around a proton of the ground state of
hydrogen has a kinetic energy of about
13.6 eb
and so tev is trillions of eb and the
two protons that collided
to create this collision event each had
a kinetic energy of about 6.5 tev
and the machine that created it as you
know is called the large hadron collider
and this is the largest machine in the
world so the large hadron collider is
a 27 kilometer circular tunnel on the
border of france and switzerland about
100 meters underground
um and in this tunnel so this is what it
looks like from the kind of aerial from
the aerial view
and in this tunnel we use
superconducting magnets that we have to
keep colder than outer space
and we use them to accelerate protons to
almost the speed of light something like
99.99999 or something of the speed of
light
and then we slam them into each other 40
million times a second and so it's the
largest machine in the world
um and it accelerates protons starting
from that little bottle of hydrogen you
saw it's really a
kind of modest bottle of hydrogen we
will never run out of protons for
probably you know if we wanted to run it
for
a million years or something um and it
starts to make it it doesn't get up to
that high energy immediately you start
at kind of smaller rings you go to
about 250 mev up to 1. 1.4 gev
and then to 25 gev and then to 450 gev
and then eventually
to 13 tev which is what you're seeing
here and the protons are kept in the
circular orbit by about 1200 dipole
magnets
there are with hundreds of other
quadrupole magnets that are used for
focusing
and they're all bathed in liquid helium
at 1.9 kelvin and this is to ensure that
they're
super conducting right so this is what
we think is probably the coldest
extended object in the universe
maybe some other civilization out there
has exceeded our uh technological
capabilities and that maybe they have
something better
but as far as we know this is probably
it um in terms of just some kind of fun
other details it takes about 45 minutes
for us to fill so so to speak the lhc
with protons
and then they collide for about 10 hours
at four points on this ring at about 40
megahertz
and so after that the kind of the the
the machine sort of dumps the beam and
then we have to start again
and the power consumption is kind of
equivalent to about one-third of that of
geneva and it's mostly taken from the
city of geneva and it's mostly taken
from france
so that's kind of like a crash course uh
in what we do right and so
no and so and this is you know this is
fascinating to us because
the thing we're really trying to do here
is
i mean not to be too glib about it but
really what we're trying to do when you
collide protons at such high energies
you're really
recreating the conditions of the
universe as they were in a very sampling
sample laboratory controlled way just
after the moment of the big bang 13.8
billion years ago and i think you know
this right but
what you you know if you look out in
space right now everything as you know
is
everything's expanding everything's
moving apart from each other and if you
look out in space
the the average temperature of the inner
of the universe is very low it's very
small right now
if it's but that's not always the case
if you just run the clock backwards
right
the youtube slider on the video
everything had to get
closer and closer together 13.8 billion
years ago everything was packed into a
tiny dense little point
so the universe at the conditions of the
universe at that moment were very very
different because things start to bump
into each other and things are radiating
and everything's really hot
so as when we collide protons at
extremely high energies we're actually
sort of recreating
the conditions of the universe back then
and this is interesting because
you know the one thing that i kind of
like to keep in mind when you think
about all this type of research to do
why are we doing this research is that
you know maybe it seems a little bit
arcane but really it's just based upon a
very very simple question which is how
small can i cut
anything right so if i you know as a new
yorker i like to take a bagel right it's
like i've been i guess i've been in
switzerland for you know seven years now
i'm not so much of a new yorker anymore
but you know take a bagel and cut the
bagel in half and keep going can you cut
the half in half keep going
you get to a crumb can you cut that of
course you get to a molecule can you cut
a molecule it's yes it's made of atoms
can you cut an atom yes it's made of
like a proton and electron
can you cut the electron as far as we
know
the answer is no can you cut a proton
though
it turns out the other stuff inside of a
proton and so this is of course the kind
of very simplistic way of thinking about
it but really
what it indic what it indicates is that
when you ask such a simple question
seemingly simple you're secretly asking
a much more profound question which was
what was holding anything together
to begin with and once you open up that
question
it has immediate implications upon
everything in existence
because if you understand those rules
about how everything fits together
you understand not just how we fit
together and how this dark matter that's
flowing through our body fits together
but also how structures formed in the
universe at all
how gold is formed in the collisions of
you know whatever neutron stars or
something like that you know you
understand this much much better
so that's really what we're going in
search of we're trying to understand
the basic rules of the universe and so i
just go through like a very quick crash
course again crash course there it is we
do this pun many times in this
in this episode i think um at the
smallest possible scales
in our universe um the universe is
composed of
tiny vibrating packets of waving
probability
and these are called particles that they
each carry energy momentum and other key
properties and these particles are
best described in fact and characterized
as
excitations in quantum fields and
they're not just
individual chunks of stuff floating
through nothing as you know
and so as a result our current
understanding of particle physics uses a
framework called quantum field theory
um of which the standard model of
particle physics which you probably have
heard of
uh of part is is one it's a very
successful example of a quantum field
theory so
most of particle physics and the uh and
the standard model which is
represented here in a nice kind of uh
schematic form
as well as physics in general follows
from or is driven by
as you know conservation laws so
quantities that the universe either
exactly or approximately conserved or
conserves or does not and i think you
know this but you know for example these
could be
very familiar things like energy and
momentum and electric charge but they
can be
more arcane things like spin and iso
spin and parody and hypercharge and
strangeness etc and combinations of all
these things
um and you know we don't have time to go
into too much of another's theorem here
but there's a deep connection of course
between
conservation laws that even the ones
that you know high school students
understand in
in physics and you know high school
physics and the mathematical symmetries
that are in the standard model
um and so this that's just a you know
kind of basic picture of what's going on
with the with the universe and the we
have
two you know as a result of all these
kind of conservation laws in the way
that we understand the
building blocks of the universe we end
up with two general classes of particles
that are based upon spin
um and we have fermions which are these
particles that have half integer spin
values and then you have bosons
that have energy spin values and so this
is again something you know
so symmetry is called gauge the special
types of symmetries there are
gauge symmetries and the standard model
and these lead to special particles that
are known
as vector gauge bosons which correspond
to
three of the known fundamental forces of
nature
and here they're sort of the ones in the
middle row here right so you have the
photon
which is the force carrying particle of
electromagnetism the w and z
which are the force carriers for the
weak force and then you have gluons
which are the force carriers for
qcd or the strong force and so
this is really fascinating because as we
see now as far as we know there are
three fundamental forces or there are
four fundamental forces but three of
which are described by the standard
model
and that and this is interesting because
at high enough scales it turns out that
our understanding of forces
gets completely messed up right so we
have we know that
at high enough energy scales for example
the electromagnetism and the weak force
are in fact two parts
of the same thing the electro weak force
and that this thing is spontaneously
broken
in the standard model which results in
exactly one scalar boson this higgs
boson which we'll talk about
a little bit in a moment here um that's
responsible for giving mass to most
elementary particles
and then uh yeah so then so these are
the bosons of the so-called vector gauge
bosons and the bosons and the higgs is
also a boson but not vector
and so that's that's the one kind of
class and then we also have these other
ones which are known as fermions that's
basically everything else
and these are quarks these are the ones
that stick together to make hadrons like
protons and neutrons
and baryons like pions and also pions
and mesons things like that
and then we also have leptons right and
so these are electrons and muons and
taus and their neutrino partners
right and so really you know if you want
sort of just like if you want to
describe the universe to
some kind of like if you had a person
that came from like a a completely
different type
of you know universe in the multiverse
you didn't know exactly what their rules
were
and they asked us how everything worked
in our universe you could tell them that
basically everything in the smallest
possible skills
uh our universe is described by fermions
exchanging bosons
and that would go a long way to
describing uh for you know in a very
kind of simple way what our universe
is i've had on a lot of our theoretical
friends that are more theoretically
inclined and
they will speak about great mysteries
such as you know the
repetition of the number three here and
we don't want to get too mystical here
on the into the impossible podcast but
the uh the repetition of three families
three generations
um and so forth uh the three different
bosons
et cetera um do we although we have an
explanation and we have an accounting we
have a taxonomy um
do we have a fundamental understanding
of you know why why
are there three of these things why why
do we have you know some
what what is the nature of the universe
is it
integer is it is it rational is it
irrational
um you know when we talk about you know
god equations and so forth
are these integer equations i always i'm
always asking my theoretically uh
minded colleagues what do you think
james yeah these are very good questions
and again these are the ones that
uh that the theorists we pay them for
their day jobs to think about for us
right
um me personally i you know i we've
talked about this in other
in slightly other capacities either on
this show or other projects that we've
done right
and so those those to me are the the
some of the most fascinating questions
but
for me as an experimentalist the answer
is we do not know
we do not know the answer to that and we
also don't have
a good explanation for what why these
patterns are the way they are they just
really are
i mean there really isn't you can make
some people try to make some arguments
about how
you know it's like you need to have
three families because of xyz um but at
the end of the day those
are they typically rely upon some other
kind of onset so they rely upon some
other kind of like
uh some other kind of assumptions and
sort of a priori there really is none
because you you know you can imagine
really you can you can write down
completely other standard you sorry you
could write down completely other
quantum field theories that are
consistent and they're renormalizable
and blah blah blah
and they in principle could have a
totally different uh structure to them
right
so this is one of the things that
theorists in my field right so that i do
high energy
particle physics collider physics um the
theorists in
a lot of the theorists in my field are
they sort of
they would often be referred to as
theorist phenomenologists right and so
they
end up having to kind of take the sort
of the
the gauge structure of the standard
model and see how you can kind of extend
that in sort of
really kind of straightforward ways or
sometimes not so straightforward to
accommodate some of the unexplained
uh phenomena right so you know the
simplest for example if you had
just an extra u1 to the the gauge group
of the standard model that could end up
giving you some extra
particles that you can search for or you
might just add something kind of simple
or you know a little bit more
complex right this this uh this gluon uh
uh this these quarks and gluons over on
the right of this little diagram right
these are all described uh or the force
that kind of holds them together
is is the strong force and the strong
force is also known as qcd right and
quantum chromodynamics and the qcd is
totally unlike the other forces right as
you know
um and it has but it's also it's also a
you know an example of a type of
uh confining gauge force right you can
have other ones
right so one of the things in fact that
i that i research a lot at the lhc
is alternate versions of qcd that could
be in the dark sector so so-called dark
qcd or dark showers
and this this leads to once you make
this kind of straightforward assumption
that maybe the dark sector
and by dark sector i mean some some kind
of secluded standard
or sorry uh quantum field theoretical
sector where there could be particles
that live and they have different masses
and things
but it's isolated from our standard
model because there's no
there's no force that we know of that
connects them so that the
particles of art of us and the particles
of this dark sector
talk together um and you can come up
with something that's not as simple you
want you can come up with something
that's more complex like an su-3 or an
su-10 or something like that and you can
also have the particular coupling
constants of this qcd could be something
completely higher and much lower and it
could have
a larger number of flavors a large
number of colors etc
so in terms of that there's there's you
know to my mind there's no good a
priority
explanation for why these patterns are
the way they are
again i'm happy to i love to hear
arguments that they're that people come
up with some
but none of them are so convincing to me
okay good thanks
i don't know what do you think are you
convinced by any of them you've been
listening to them for a long time yeah
yeah i mean you know the fundamental
question
you know i think is is a good one i
think it's a profound one
some say that yeah only two of them are
fundamental
uh and of course there are you know
questions as you say how do they relate
to
you know higher embeddings are they
manifestations
of of of uh you know just our
lower order glimpses at these but again
this is
stuff that i don't particularly traffic
in you know my my questions will
will be you know much more primitive but
um but certainly things like you know i
think
the the departures from symmetries you
know people we focus a lot on the
symmetries the group behaviors
but it's really you know the departures
of symmetries that fascinate me more
you know i i always joke you know make
the joke with you but
you know when they when they say you
know symmetry is beautiful and we should
look for symmetry and i had frank
wilcheck on many times and
and uh you know he obviously talks about
this in a beautiful question
and but if you if you do studies and
even in art you know you take like the
most handsome
man in the world as besides the two of
us
is reputed to be brad pitt and they do
studies they take brad pitt and they
they cut him down the middle and they
reflect the left half of his face in the
right half and he's grotesque
and he's disgusting even more than he is
normally compared to the two of us
and um and so it's really the departure
that means departure even
artistic and and physiological beauty uh
departure so
anyway i think we talk a lot about
neither and and it is you know obviously
a wonderful
theorem but but it's really the
departure and the spontaneous symmetry
that's broke
and one wonders if if that you know then
does
imply if there's something even more
primitive that higher energies and
and maybe that's where we'll come but we
should move on because you have so many
cool things to show and we have
a limited time before our next uh our
next experimental you know i always say
i thought astronomers lived on
telescopes but we live on telecon so
we
no it's okay i mean these are really
these are really important questions
these are really important questions
right so i you know again i i totally
agree with you that this is what i think
you know why i always mention when i
talk about symmetries and notice theorem
is that yeah
symmetries are are uh you know it's an
observation about the universe right
and what that means is that but that but
the tree the reality is that the
universe
uh obeys some of those symmetries it
respects them and completely violates
other ones
right so that's that to me is you know
again i totally agree with you right
it's like
the the sort of um the deviation from a
symmetry can be much more fascinating
sometimes right you know why does
why does cp violation happen maximally
in one sector
but completely not at all observed in
another sector you know what you know
this is this is a fascinating
question right and if somebody can come
up with a a wonderful elegant a period
of reason for that i would be
i like your theory but i haven't heard
it yet so okay so we're going to keep
going
um and so but the important thing for us
for and for the
you know the notion of a circular
collider on the moon
um is that the elementary particles that
we know of
they in fact all the ones that you see
right here on this thing they have a
very wide range of masses and as you
know in spell
special relativity mass and energy are
related so
this is important for collider
physicists because you know if nature
has a particle with a mass m that's
extremely high that's kinetic
higher than the kinetic energy that you
know e that we as physicists
have ever used in a collider experiment
will never be able to produce it
directly and then in abundance and
measure its properties and so that's
where
again so much of what we do comes down
to einstein at the end of the day right
is that and by produce what i mean is
that when we
collide two particles together they're
you know again it's sort of like a kind
of a kind of a glib way
but you know it's a it's a good
heuristic right is that their wave
functions can overlap
right and they can interfere to create
new states and it these if these states
exist in nature right if it's an actual
resonance in nature
and so in this case the two particles
that came to collide they actually
ceased to exist
and a new particle is created in their
place that lives for a small amount of
time
before then decays into other things
that had our detector that fly away from
the collision point
and hit our detector and so this is
schematically drawn here by one of these
kind of fimon diagrams
and you know when we collide protons
it's actually not the typically the
protons don't actually hit head on
uh and and collide typically you end up
they end up being able to get close
enough so that they interact the
individual quarks or gluons can get
pulled out and those are the things that
collide
oh and this is just a leftover from uh
yeah so this but the particle in the
middle is the thing we're kind of
interested in right so
this could be a z boson or this could be
a new thing like the higgs boson
or it could be something totally
different like a dark photon or
something like that
that we're looking for um and the reason
why
we right now as i keep emphasizing right
now is such a fascinating time
uh to be alive as a physicist is that we
again we have this this this wild number
of open
questions in physics but really no more
hints
and those hints are you know it to me we
have to kind of
retrain our brain brains as particle
physicists
to get away from the kind of 20th
century mindset to be honest
because the 20th century was
magnificently
lucky we basically was like clockwork
you can start here's like a very
breakneck history of uh instead
of of particle physics in the 20th
century you start from
you know 1897 thompson was able to
discover the electron
by himself on a tabletop and then in
1919 the proton came from out of nowhere
and then
1932 the neutron and then you discovered
muons and then
uh neutrinos and then back into the 60s
you we realize that there's actually
structure down inside uh
things like protons and neutrons which
are known as protons
and then you get to 1974 when the when
the jsi particle was discovered
and this more or less definitively
demonstrated that the charm quark was
real which
made people take seriously this notion
of uh quarks and gluons as
not just a bookkeeping tool but actual
legitimate individual particles
and then you had the tau lepton and then
you had the gluon and then you had the w
and z bosons
which were more or less kind of
predicted to be right within this kind
of energy ranged and pow there they were
and then the top quark and the last
remaining piece to be plugged into all
of this was the higgs boson which my
colleagues and i discovered in 2012
at the lac congratulations and and
that's a fascinating place to be
because oh and just a quick sort of like
side note in terms of personal history
here so
uh martin pearl was the discovery uh you
know leaving the group that discovered
the tao
he had a student uh who's named sam ting
uh who was
part of the team that discovered the jsi
one of the two teams sam team had a
student who was named salvon wu
uh who was one of the teams that
discovered the gluon salon woo works
with
me on atlas and also with my advisor
kyle cranmer
and kyle cranmer was one of the editors
of the paper that discovered the higgs
boson
in atlas so where does that leave me
because sam ting in addition to
the last four letters of my last name uh
sam ting
is the phd advisor of the new uh project
uh executive project manager of the
simon's observatory
uh gary sanders who is a former project
manager
of tmt and ligo so he is now
working at uc san diego at simon's
observatory and he
was you know directly responsible for
the nobel prize
et cetera by uh by my friends uh barry
barrish guest on the show ray weiss
guest on the show and uh
kip thorne hopefully soon to be guest on
the show that's really uh it's really
fun to see them up there
yeah oh it's a it's it's such a you know
it's interesting to kind of look at your
genealogy in terms of
not just your own phd but also the
people that you've kind of touched
throughout your career it's wonderful
small world but the interesting thing
here right is that once you have the
higgs boson what's left right and so
the higgs boson was this fascinating
thing right and for us in particle
physics july 4th
2012 was sort of the day where where
everything changed because
after you know collecting and analyzing
uh you know
uh collisions at a center of mass
collision energy of
seven and eight tev we in the atlas
collaborations announced the discovery
of a new particle that was consistent
with the
uh observation of a standard model higgs
boson
and this was a monumentally monumental
achievement and seemingly
completed the standard model but the lhc
was designed to go to higher energies
and so on june 3rd
uh in 2015 uh many of us gathered in
this
you know atlas control room to observe
the first ever collisions at this
highest energy 13 tev
that we'd ever seen before and this was
applause and champagne and it was really
a lot of fun
and it was a very heady time because we
because we didn't have any idea what
we're going to find
in this data because the higgs again was
the last remaining piece to be plugged
into the standard model
and beyond that we don't know what
there's going to be we know there have
to be things but
but we don't know what they're going to
be and so uh and
and so yeah just to emphasize the point
again sorry and this is interesting
because
you think about the higgs boson as this
gigantic discovery a wonderful thing
and this is the case this is the way
things happen right so like this is the
number of open questions in physics
before
july 4th 2012 right does the higgs boson
exist
you know what is dark matter how does
what's the universe's expansion you know
uh
how what why are these particular
families of corpse leptons the way they
are
um you know what are neutrinos what are
the masses you know why they have the
hierarchy they do
and then after the discovery this is the
number of open questions the higgs only
answered one
and it opened up a huge number of other
questions right so this is again why i
say that this is a fascinating a
wonderful time to be a physicist but
it's also very daunting
because i can tell you that now as we
have collected more data at this 13 tev
we have successfully established a wide
range of results that are consistent
with standard model expectations
also known as we have discovered no new
particles so far
beyond the higgs and this is the biggest
open question right now is that where
does the standard model lose validity
right because that's the thing it's like
we get to this point where the standard
model
has the strange you know the strange
ordering of masses of particles and
things like that but we
know that it's incomplete we know for a
fact that it's incomplete
it doesn't include gravity it doesn't
include dark matter or dark energy
doesn't explain the matter antimatter
asymmetry of the universe et cetera et
cetera et cetera
there's no comprehensive explanation for
why the structure is the way it is right
and the kicker
the kicker is that in principle it could
be applicable all the way up to the
point scale
so the the plot scale is a 10 to the 16
gev
and or they're so so we have the lhc
down here
and there could be discoveries or or so
it could be applicable all the way up to
the clock scale in principle
it's a bit weird but okay maybe or there
could be discoveries anywhere between
our tv scale and up to the
the plonk energy and so that's really
where we finally get to the this idea
right is like
we need to think we to my mind we need
to change our brains as physicists when
we think about collider physics
and instead of saying oh we need to
build you know this collider this
particular energy
because i want to discover x instead we
think
how big can we go and to measure
different things
about the standard model predictions in
all of these energy ranges
up to and including the planck scale and
it's a different mindset right it's
it's not like we're going to discover
supersymmetry i'm going to discover
squirks and gluings i'm going to
discover the higgs
instead it's like what can we do with
the current technology and future
technology to get as high as possible
i've been phrasing it lately you know
are we putting the the toe before the
gut
i mean we don't you know we everyone's
fascinated with the theory of everything
we don't correct me if i'm wrong james
you're so much more of an expert than i
am we don't have a grand unified theory
that everybody agrees on correct or or
am i wrong no no no there's there's many
competing ideas and things flowing
around that
we don't even have that yes you're right
yeah
yeah and this is the desert is that the
desert that they talk about james is
this what you're depicting here
this is the desert yes this is the
desert and again
you i love to discuss with my theorist
colleagues about different
uh you know um motivation so to speak
for
where the new you know where the new
scale of particles and fields could show
up
where that will help us uh you know help
us explain things and
but at the end of the day those are all
based upon some kind of assumptions or
some kind of you know
some kind of uh uh unsats or they're
honestly based upon
you know the kind of prediction as to
what we can possibly do it's like oh
you know for example super symmetry is a
great idea right super symmetry speaking
of symmetries
this is not a super symmetry show but
again super symmetry is a fantastic idea
there's nothing it's neither wrong nor
right it's just a really wonderful idea
that the universe either observes or
does not observe
we haven't seen any uh evidence of it so
far but the issue with supersymmetry is
that it has such a large parameter space
that the masses and the the scale of
these particles could show up
really a lot you know a huge range of
places and as you're pointing out with
respect to like grand unified theories
and things like that
for for example the scale at which uh
the electro weak and the strong force
become one thing that's in principle
something extremely high too from a very
kind of simple
i i guess the what is it the the georgia
and glashow uh perspective would be
something like
uh i'm gonna get this wrong but it's
like that's gonna be 10
something like that but it's like 10 if
like you know six or seven orders of
magnitude
higher in energy than what we have now
something like that i don't know we we'd
get the exact number but that's
that's that's pretty large but it's also
that's one particular idea it could be
in principle the other things
can we go back a slide um or two let me
just see um
yeah stop uh go forward one more slide
uh one more
yeah this one so when you're looking at
their uh in the middle
and you're all excited there tell me on
a daily basis or
you know in a in a decade-long basis it
takes you to get your phd and
in your field like what do you do i know
what i do you know my students are in
the lab across the building here i can
see them now they're working hard all
right guys um
you know we're testing balometers which
are ultra sensitive power detectors that
can detect a billionth of a billionth of
a watt in one second
you know we're making basically
sensitive uh thermal heat detectors that
have to be ultra cold
you you showed that you know our data
look like time series data
um these are very sophisticated images
you know fast image pro
tell me a little bit about what's it
like to be an experimentalist a graduate
student
what was some of the training you got
what was your um you know as an
undergraduate what's like the right
preparation
that someone gets is it is it you know
because a theoretician it's obvious you
know i always say like
to be a theoretical physicist is like
kind of what they train you for
at all of graduate school uh
undergraduates like all the theoretical
class they're all theoretical i mean
you take a lab but it's already
pre-packaged somebody wanted to know
about projects for 50 years ago
davidson yeah whatever but it's like
it's nothing like what you do in
graduate school as a graduate student
experimental astrophysics so
tell me what do you do to train to
become the graduate student that you
were
and and what is a graduate student
actually doing on a daily basis
yeah so a large percentage of what uh
graduate students that work on
these big experiments at the lhc do a
large percentage of it is uh
data science so a huge amount of it is
data you know analytics and
um uh data reduction uh
you know with with physics reasoning
based upon what you're doing of course
um so a large amount of is you know just
being conversant with uh how to
manipulate data and how to manipulate
code
um but that's that's just sort of
percentage-wise what we end up doing
that's a lot of it right but we also end
up writing papers and blah blah but to
the training thing
so to answer your question actually to
give a little bit of history for me i'm
uh
i had a completely different bachelor's
degree first in uh the arts in film
um and then i realized i was still
obsessed with physics uh
and specifically particle physics that i
always been obsessed with these with
these kind of two things since i was a
kid
um cinema is a very a fascinating way of
exploring
complex ideas but then also really
understanding the basic rules of
everything around us
and so i went back and did a second
bachelor's degree in physics and math
everyone said i was crazy but uh you
know here i am it worked out
and what i did and just to give you know
kind of uh just to give a little bit of
um uh you know uh
credit where credit is due based upon
the thing you said at the first part of
the show too
i just started with community college
courses right because they're not going
to let you into a
physics phd program if you don't have
you know an actual phd
i'm sorry if you don't have a bachelor's
degree in physics and math so i started
with community college courses and i did
my basics
you know at community college so i'm 100
with you in terms of public schools and
the we need to
ensure huge funding for those as much
you know robust funding
uh in perpetuity that's part of the
mission of this channel is like
supplement and augment i love community
college i love public schools but
nowadays with youtube i mean you're a
lot younger than i am but but nowadays
you can get so much education it's all
free
and channels like mine our friends
sabina others doing a lot of um
a lot of work to popularize this for
free and you can do stuff nowadays as i
say my job is to
you know you guys should always be
curious abc and you i'm creating the
university i wish existed that you can
attend with no student loan debt in your
pajamas
taught by professors like dr james
beacham for free you know in your
pajamas
yeah but yeah go ahead i don't want to
lose track of the i want to get to the
moon
yeah i know we got to get to the moon
too but i completely agree with you and
actually just in terms of keeping it
local with uh with you
i did those two years of uh of
introductory physics courses to
reintroductory physics courses at san
diego community college so
there we go you know anyway
so yeah so what you do as a physicist is
as an experimentalist these days with
the high energy
physics is you again a lot of data
analysis a lot of coding but also just
physical reasoning right so you really
do need to understand the physics behind
some you know data analysis you're going
to do this is a huge data set that's
gigantic even as an undergrad or like a
grad student if you're working on these
experiments it's a very large data set
so you need to use physical reasoning to
hone in on some subset of the data and
then due to data reduction and
figure out exactly what it is you're
looking for you need to go back to the
first principles from even finding
diagrams the theory maybe uh that
inspires what you're looking for maybe
you're looking for a z
prime particle a new force carrying
particle maybe looking for quantum black
holes
this you have to understand how that
might show up in your detector as a
particular
uh signature right and as a grad student
you do a large
amount of that type of thing you know
physical reasoning
simulating events uh doing the data
analysis
and then writing papers but as an
experimentalist you also get to fiddle
around with electronics
and hardware and because these detectors
i mean atlas is
six stories high 46 meters long it's
like a gigantic soda can
tipped on its side and filled with
extremely complicated electronics and
all these pieces
come from all over the world so they are
manufactured and designed
all over the world you got a piece from
israel you got a piece from japan you
got a piece from
uh you know from sweden a piece from
multiple places in the u.s
and they all have to be come together as
a you know clockwork and come together
and really fit this thing
and it's it's almost it's astounding in
so many ways that it works
the way it does it's really sort of the
the definition of um
laudable global collaboration which is
very related
to my idea for this uh circular collider
on the moon
and so the interstellar inter intersolar
system
beyond global yes well exactly yeah
exactly it's a solar system
collaboration yes um so yeah we'll get
we'll get to these uh
you know as you said we should sort of
start pushing forward and so the
motivation for
so that again to kind of like recenter
ourselves in terms of the story
right it's like we right now we have
we have looked at this 13 tev that we
have at the lhc
this energy range that allows us to get
to sort of a maximal mass range of what
a new particle could be
and it could if it exists in nature we
could be able to produce it in abundance
and discover it outright right
but beyond that we have to go to higher
energies and again
it's it's it really it's a completely
meaningless question to ask how
motivated is a bigger collider it really
isn't it's completely meaningless
because there's no
there's no way for you to point towards
something the motivation target we
we don't know the motivation is we don't
know the mass scale of
of new particles and fields we therefore
have to go as high as we can the
syllogism is completely complete
you can't argue with it you can't argue
with the
with the with the amount of resources
that it might take to build something
but you can't argue with the the logical
syllogism that gets you to that
conclusion
and it comes from just the fact that you
can we've done this our entire
you know our entire physics lifetime
last hundred years
every more than a hundred years every
time we built something bigger
we've learned new things about the
universe or as i say james this time is
not different
no it it is not it's it's just a
continuation of what we've done
i agree so yeah starting back in 19 you
know in 1897 where you could really you
know really could
uh discover something by yourself on a
tabletop right this is
an amazing time i'm sure but then of
course the connection sorry
i can't resist connection to cnb
polarization the father of thompson
scattering
thompson's cross section that's where
cmb polarization comes from j.j thompson
absolutely
keep going yep absolutely keep it yes
you know these these guys uh really
changed the change the world completely
in many ways
and then yeah so in terms of shout outs
we got to shout out eo lawrence as well
right because he built the first
the world's first cyclotron right which
more or less accelerated particles in
this circle right in
in this thing you can hold in your hand
and i think this one is actually at
berkeley somewhere like in a museum or
something um
and this what this did is it provided in
principle a way to control these
particles trajectories into a circle so
that you could use them for something
such as bombarding a target or
eventually to collide particles together
right and so
the kinetic energy to which you can
accelerate a particle in a circular
collider
depends mainly upon the size of your
collider and the strength of the magnets
that you use to bend them
right and so this was the first one
which was 36 centimeters
in circumference so bigger machines big
bigger energies
and therefore bigger possibility of
discovery so then you have the proton
synchrotron
628 meters around 59 i'm skipping over
some things right but like
just to kind of get us to the next in a
sense the next big thing
people ask this question sometimes i
have no idea what this guy's the buckets
i have asked the cern archivists and
they don't know either
he's he's probably you know controlling
for some kind of uh
cooling leak or something i don't know i
have no idea what he's doing
then to put this kind of in context we
had something like you know this
we had something like the um the uh the
proton synchrotron 628 meters
in circumference and that got to 24 gev
and just in contrast this is a thompson
and so on the bottom you'll see what it
is that we discovered
when we went to a bigger collider right
so then
uh when you go to then we had something
called the alternating gradient secret
rom which is one of the two experiments
that discovered the
the jsi or the charm quark this is the
1960s 800 meters
big step forward right then you had
something called the super proton
synchrotron also at cern
seven kilometers around mind-blowing
right 540 gev completely unprecedented
yeah
then you had something like the tevatron
which is a jump forward as well in
energy because of the different magnet
technology they use but it's around the
same as a similar size range right
and this is the 1983 83 and of course we
discovered the top quark oh yeah and
then of course
the sps the blue one the w and the z
bosons were discovered
momentous to cajun if anybody ever comes
to visit me at cern
i come i give them the behind the scenes
james tour
the vip tour and i take them to the
shaft where you can look down
and i could point down and say down
there in that little place there that's
where they discovered the w and z bosons
and everybody's mind is blown when they
see that it's great
i should have put a photo of it here
then you had the large hadron collider
this is a huge step forward right so
basically similar technology right you
have to have superconducting magnets or
you know very strong magnets to get
something up to higher energies
27 kilometers around yeah but again
this is the highest one we have now and
we're at this desert like you said this
desert we have the lhc here the
discovery could be anywhere
so how far up do we go the next idea of
course is this notion of the fcc right
the future circular collider and that's
a big step we have to do this there's no
question
if we don't we'll never know what's
there right this is the idea to get
something that's like 100
kilometers around and would reach up to
the sort of like hundreds of tev range
that's a huge step forward beyond that
what do we do right is there some but
that's not the all that's not the only
idea right so like
we have the we have the uh uh oh and of
course
on the the bottom here when you have the
lhc that's where the higgs boson was
discovered but that's the last piece
that's the last guaranteed discovery
beyond that we have huge open questions
and no guarantee
so the next machine could either be
something like a future circular
collider at cern
or a similar you know size thing maybe
80 kilometers i don't know
called the cepc which would then have a
successor which would be the sppc
these would refer to at first you'd
start collecting electron positron which
means you can do precision measurements
of the higgs boson and other particles
and then after that you can use the same
tunnel to build something that would
collide protons that would be one of
these jump it jumps up in energy right
and one of these going to happen right
this is 2040s this is something we're
looking for into the future right
and so there's also been a an idea
floated if you will
to have a collider in the sea and so
these are some of some of my colleagues
in the u.s
such as peter mcintyre texas a m they
are you know
uber accelerator experts and they have
the same attitude
toward particle physics in the future
that i do they say
we don't know what the next scale of
particles of fields is let's go as big
as we can
we can we can reasonably do so that's
technologically possible in the next few
decades
so this is an idea where they would
actually float a collider
at neutral buoyancy at a rate in about
100 meters under the gulf of mexico
and they in principle think that the
technology is possible to do that this
could maybe get to 500 tv or 700 tev
it's not possible to know when that's
going to happen
however beyond that what do we do right
what
is it possible for us to get bigger than
that what if instead we were to think
about building
a circular collider around the moon so
this would be something that could get
this would be 11 000 kilometers around
and principal could get to 14 pev
and this is the idea so a few decades
sorry a few years ago this is the idea
that i would float to blow people's
minds like what if we could do this and
like kind of inspire them it's like you
should do this and you should find this
and maybe we could do this but i never
really put it down on the page
and now i put it down on the page and so
this is a this is an article that we put
out just a few days ago um on the
archive with my colleague frank
zimmerman
i can go into some details about frank
but he in fact was one of my
sort of uh very inspiring idols um
i happened to come across and actually
one of the people that sort of blew my
minds about ten
it blew my mind about ten years ago i
happened to come across
uh i happened to be in the room with uh
uh
for a talk that he gave at an aps
meeting in denver i was there presenting
on something else
and he gave this talk about future
colliders and things and then at the end
he's like oh and beyond that
you know beyond terrestrial collaterals
maybe at some point we could think about
getting bigger ones
such as floating a circular collider i'm
sorry floating uh
floating a linear collider in space
between the earth and the moon
and i was just like i was a grad student
i'm like whoa
this blows my mind so i think frank was
the natural person for me to
uh call upon about you know six months
ago when i decided
i said hey why don't we put this down as
an actual kind of you know a concrete
idea
right and so in principle this could get
to something like a thousand times
the energy of the lhc but of course
there are some uh challenges to such an
idea right
um this is the moon and of course it
would not look like this
probably it would end up looking uh like
this instead
so this is the face that always faces
there's one as you know the moon and
earth are tidally locked
and so we basically see the same side of
the moon all the time
and due to uh various features of
the of the moon um it turns out that
probably the best trajectory for such a
thing would be to loop around the moon
kind of like the the the around the edge
that we see
from earth the front part of the the
moon is very smooth compared to the back
part which is extremely rocky
and it turns out you can kind of like
find a trajectory that's in there
that sort of hopefully avoids a lot of
the a lot of the
um uh the elevation changes that you
would have to
uh potentially you know uh
address if you wanted to do such a thing
but of course before we get too far we
should ask the question
why a circular collider on the moon
right so obviously the science part is
to me clear i hope i've made the case
that we need to go as big as we can
that's technologically possible with any
reasonable amount of time
and that will give us a such something
like this would give us three orders of
magnitude jump and collision energy
which would open up huge uh potential
for discovery
and the um the other uh the other ques
the other reason for this would be that
building something larger than what we
currently have on the earth is going to
be tougher and tougher the bigger we get
and i'll have a tiny bit of detail on
this in a moment but the last one
is to me the most important reason and
because it seems inevitable that humans
are going to return to the moon
so we need to keep this in mind when we
when we think about what it means to go
back to the moon and i hope to expand
upon that for a couple of minutes
at the very end but just to kind of
emphasize
you might the the one of the biggest uh
you know objections might be
okay the moon is 11 000 kilometers you
could definitely fit that on the earth
somewhere so why don't you just do it on
the earth
okay that's true what if we were to
build something like this that could
circle all the way around i mean in
principle you could fit it all the way
completely in russia maybe
depends if you do that you're already
immediately going to go underneath huge
mountain ranges and you're going to also
and
inevitably because you'd have to have
anytime you you know you if you'd wanted
uh to build a tunnel underneath you're
going to end up having to have a lot of
different access shafts everywhere
you ended up displacing local
populations you'd end up you know just
really sort of
disrupting a lot of people's lives is
that the way to go maybe that's the
better way i don't really know
but it seems to me that it's going to be
very very difficult to do that also
it's going to be very difficult to a
certain extent to get a large global
collaboration
to do something that is that is owned by
one particular country
um these days you in principle could
also do it down here
okay maybe you could but any anywhere
you pick that's sort of land-based
that's a similar size
you're going to end up digging
underneath gigantic things such as the
himalayas right i mean i don't know how
you're going to avoid the himalayas if
you wanted to do something like this
in principle you could also just put it
in the ocean however
you could do something much larger in
the pacific ocean in fact however
i don't know how you're going to control
the currents that you would get in there
so the guys for the gulf of mexico
because
the currents that are in the gulf of
mexico are much milder than what you get
on the large scale
um in the in the pacific ocean i'm not
sure you could achieve
the same technology of this you know
find some kind of neutral buoyancy
um technology that would enable such a
thing in the pacific ocean
again i'm happy to be proven wrong you
know because part of the reason why
you even write a project or write a
paper like this is to kind of just you
know
raise the idea so that maybe somebody
can knock it down and come up with a
better idea
right so these are the reasons why um
and why you would want to do something
on the moon instead and so
to me the the idea of putting something
on the moon
is interesting because of that right
it's like doing something on the earth
seems like a larger and larger energy
seems like it's going to be very very
difficult
um and oh in fact let's see
i should i want to show this slide first
before
before i go to the other slides and so i
just want to kind of mention that
this is not necessarily the craziest
idea that you have heard because
ideas like this have been around for a
very long time so if you flash back to
1954 just before he died
enrico fermi predicted that a globaltron
encircling the earth would be built by
1994
right and in his mind this would reach a
collision energy of
5pev and in 1954 dollars it would cost
170 million
uh dollars so this is an idea really
that has just been around for quite some
time
and it's just this sort of continuation
of that other thing
and just um we we should wrap up
probably about 10 to 12 minutes james
just because i have another call coming
in
but um the u.s antarctic program is in
part stationed at the south pole with
the cmb telescopes
ice cube et cetera because it's uh the
only way that we maintain
legal and military whatever presence at
the south pole which you can barely see
in the image here
uh from earth rise so you know
strategically it may be a
part of the us you know space force
command ironically pitting you in in
parallel with your uh favorite president
the previous pro no i'm just kidding
but uh but yes so that that's another
quiver in your arrow for the
lunar collider but yeah so let's keep
going for sure yeah i'll just wrap up in
a few minutes here so
i mean we could go on for a very long
time but you know
um but you know this is the the idea
behind it and just to give a few of the
kind of technical details i i encourage
people to kind of read the paper and
obviously criticize we've already had
some really good comments that people
have you know that have come up with
um because i like to see all the you
know flaws in my thinking as any good
scientist
uh should right and so you depend
based upon so in the in the paper we
paint like three possible scenarios as
to how to
dig something like or build something
like this one you put on the surface
this is more or less a no-go because the
temperature variations from
lunar day to night are huge and you if
you wanted to build something
very large on the surface you'd need to
have the magnets be super conducting
and you can use something called high
temperature superconductors but that's
also high in that case is very very low
compared to what we have
in on you know uh on like earth um
uh you know um room temperature right in
principle
the when the moon is in shade the
temperatures do get low enough so you
could use high temperature
superconductors
but that only happens for a very small
amount of time if you have an entire
ring on the outside right it's like it's
going to go around and only
for like a maybe an hour or something
the entire thing was going to be in
shape
that's a deal breaker you could in
principle do with what we call a cut and
cover right you could dig a trench
just a few meters underneath and then
put some put some uh some regolith on
top
this is the soil and the on the moon
right if you do that you're still not
going to completely win everything
because you're still that the day night
temperature variations are still maybe
going to be a problem
but if you even get a few uh a few
dozens of centimeters underneath the the
lunar surface
the temperature is fixed but and not
cold enough
to be and to ensure uh high temperature
high temperature superconductors
so you're going to have to use a cooling
system anyway no matter what you do it
seems
so and also if it's just underneath the
surface you are open to possible
meteoroid strikes that can actually do
some damage right you don't want that to
happen
so probably the best way is to really
dig a tunnel and so that's why this is
uh
schematically here you might dig
something maybe 200 meters under the
surface or something like that
and so really just uh we we happen to
kind of look and see
at uh you know at the the you know
temperature i'm sorry the
elevation variations that you see on the
moon here and if you look very closely
you can find a trajectory that seems to
miss some of the largest uh the
elevation
uh changes although of course not all of
them and this is
we left for future work a lot of uh a
lot of things in this paper
one of which is to do a very detailed uh
use like a detailed geological survey of
the moon
to uh find a very like the kind of
perfect trajectory
because if you look closely at even this
image you'll see
that there's a big problem in one of
these places for example right there
so this in principle would demonstrate
that you're going to have to have
if you're if you're going to dig this
thing a few a couple of hundred meters
under the surface of the moon but at
some point you're just going to go over
one of these large
mare and this is the this is the uh
humble
hum humboldt hump ultienum i believe
yeah and this is this is like something
like five kilometers deep
so this is a problem right however one
of the
again i'm just giving you a flavor of
the sort of things you have to think
about as an experimentalist you know
as you know but just to give people a
flavor so if you're digging
and you've got five kilometers
underneath you you think okay this is
crazy how are we gonna build like an
actual structure like a tube
that has to go over five kilometers and
somehow like hold it up
first of all i think that any
civilization that is sufficiently
advanced to
dig a tunnel around the entire uh
surface of the you know 100 meters under
the surface 200 meters on the surface of
the moon would be able to solve such a
problem
the other part is that you probably on
the moon don't even need
a beam enclosure you could actually have
a bare beam in some places
because the the vacuum on the the moon
is
much much better than even the vacuum
that we have down in the that we
actually have to super pump down in the
lhc itself so in principle you can just
have this beam shooting over the entire
mario itself
so we're i'm just sort of wrapping up
here i just wanted to kind of get to
some of the
the you know the kind of fun details
people have been thinking about going
back to the moon a lot for a very long
time obviously so
an idea like this really just sort of
piggybacks on so many fantastic ideas
that have come before it so for example
people are thinking about using these
lunar lava tubes which are leftover kind
of pop
pop marks underneath the surface that
could principle could be gigantic and
you could host entire cities
you don't want things to be on the
surface because of you'll get a lot of
cosmic radiation that could in principle
just kill
humans if they're based upon the surface
for a very long amount of time right
one of the biggest problems that we face
is powering and i just want to give a
flavor of the powering here right
and so you probably but based upon our
calculations you would need some kind of
10 terawatt source uh to uh power the
ccm
this is a challenge because uh you can
estimate that approximately the entire
uh power consumption of humanity um is
at the kind of 20 terawatts level
so then you need something that would be
about half of what uh taking up half of
the energy we currently use at all
this is not necessarily such a problem
because you can imagine using some kind
of
uh solar power right because the sun is
giving out all this free power all the
time
here down on earth we have atmosphere to
deal with we have you know in
inefficient uh
we have efficient you know solar panels
et cetera et cetera on the moon that's
not such a problem so
this kind of calculations you would need
a little patch about the size of
delaware
to that's entirely really good solar
panels and you could power the entire
thing
however that is that patch is not going
to be in the sun
in the sun all the time because the moon
of course has this you know this day
night which is about
30 you know it has like 13.8 earth days
is one of their days
so instead why don't you build an entire
belt a dyson belt around the entire
equator of the
of the moon at that guarantees that at
some point at some point on the moon is
always
uh in as always in the sun when i wrote
this down for the paper i was like oh
that's really that's good i'm sure
somebody else has thought about that and
of lo and behold of course somebody has
thought about this there's an entire
corporation uh in japan
the shimizu corporation they they
actually took this seriously this idea
did i did been around for a long time
but they took this seriously after the
fukushimi
fukushima daiichi um power plant failure
they think how is
how could we actually solve earth's uh
power needs
and one of these is the this lunar ring
idea anyway et cetera et cetera we can
go on for a very long time but
the the biggest things that come to mind
is like where are you going to
manufacture all this stuff are you going
to just take these things from earth and
and transport them to the moon no you
want to manufacture things on the moon
luckily people have been thinking about
that for a long time so of course we get
to the kind of money ideas
what's the budget for such a thing it's
nearly impossible to estimate
given what we know right and what's the
timeline 2100s
we don't really know right the key thing
here is not necessarily to give a
particular timeline right it's not we're
not necessarily supposed
we're not trying to again it's not a
proposal right this is just an idea
for something that we could do right
it's a it's sort of a proof of concept
in a way
um and you know because the the most
important part of my kind of reasons you
want to do this
to me is that bottom one and just to
finish up here the bottom one was that
it seems as though humans are going to
go back to the moon inevitably i mean
this
seems that's the direction everything's
going right so you know back in the 60s
of course then
you know you've got the international
space station but then of course you now
have current things like spacex and nasa
are collaborating
and really getting better at getting you
know eventually getting back to the moon
and of course nasa has been thinking
about moon bases for a very long time
and you've got people like you know the
people at this moon express right there
like return to the moon this time to
stay and then you've got like the google
lunar x prize right sort of like trying
to bribe people to you know corporations
to go back to the moon right
and my idea is that we should instead
instead of just
thinking about what it is that we can
you know we can like allow
private corporations to do on the moon
we should instead
center projects that actually benefit
all of humanity
that to me is the most important thing
because i'll be honest with you i'm
going to get a little bit sentimental
here
i personally left my own devices i would
prefer that we
um protect the moon against commercial
commercial exploitation in perpetuity
i would prefer that that's probably
impossible instead i think what we
should do with a proposal you know this
is
kind of my idea with a with an idea like
a ccm let's center
projects that are for the public good
because the ccm is
you know things like the lhc they pay
for themselves many times over with the
people that you train the technology
that they're invented that could be
transferred to private industry et
cetera et cetera these things pay for
themselves over and over and over
but the reason we do them is simply
because we're curious about the universe
and about our place in the universe so
that's why you know you'd have something
like this and it would not just be a ccm
it would be an l park right this would
be the lunar particle and astrophysics
research center
astronomy very long baseline neutrino
experiment between earth and moon et
cetera et cetera you can do all these
things
this to me is the most important part
because we as it stands now
we're basically just giving up space and
the moon and mars to billionaires
and that to me is extremely immoral and
super depressing to be honest it's like
i
don't you know when so many of us have
also been losing our jobs through the
pandemic
and like getting sick billionaires
increase their
you know their their wealth by like what
1.2 trillion or something like that
and if you've seen this most recent pro
public i think it's kind of nice that
you know
ccm uh idea comes out the day before the
pro publica
article comes out that shows that all
these billionaires basically paying no
taxes at all
right we should not be giving contracts
to my mind we should not be giving them
just sort of giving them to these
guys instead we should be taxing them
and and compelling them to pay
us to get to go to the moon anyway so
that's the whole idea for me is that i
would like to i would like people to
keep in mind that
when we set you know the moon should
belong to all of us
and if we were to keep in mind ideas
like you know it doesn't have to be a
ccm i mean
again this notion of like the lunar ring
around the ring that
very much changes the appearance of the
moon from earth
and maybe that's a deal breaker we don't
want to do that maybe because it'll
change the way that people you know
it ruins poetry for a very long time
right and so
you know again but if we center
something like a ccm or like you know a
science center that has you know uh like
telescopes on the far side of the moon
right so that they're radio quiet etc
these are fantastic ideas
these instead will remind us that moon
the moon in space and mars
these things that allow us you know to
to think big
they really should belong to all of us
it should not just be in the hands of a
few
it's a different kind of inspiration
well james thank you so much for
going into the impossible some say it
was impossible to get to the south pole
some say it would be impossible to build
a collider
under two different countries that were
historically you know battling uh for
for resources for hundreds of years uh
prior to
the construction of cern etc which has
been great for peace
great for training great for advancing
knowledge i'll put links to uh
to to different videos that we've had
previous appearances by james
i will put them on the screen in various
locations
i want to point out i've had jessica
meer who was on the space station that
you showed and she is a member project
artemis i'm hoping she'll be the first
woman
to walk on the moon i'll put a link to
that somewhere
and maybe may we go back for all man and
woman kind
uh in peace and uh and for for the
benefit of
our species that is absolutely what what
science is good for and james i want to
thank you for your creativity
for your insight and for inspiring
people hopefully there's a young person
out there
who uh will be just as inspired as i am
by the inventedness the inquisitiveness
but also there's really grounded
hardcore science that's going on here
uh james has the best of both worlds
you're doing something that is
um low risk high reward and high risk
and high reward and i think that's
that's a really smart strategy you want
to diversify your portfolio
just like you do in economics and you
want to do that with your research
portfolio as well
james thank you so much for going into
the impossible
thanks brian okay let me end
uh i'm gonna end the video here